[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici
depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme comment assurer
une évaluation juste et équitable pour
nos lycéens
faut-il envisager un baccalauréat au
niveau européen notre reporter jonathan
du prix s est rendu en allemagne qui
fait la part belle au contrôle continu
mais d'une région à l'autre
certains estiment que les examens ne se
valent pas nous questionnons entre
autres ce modèle allemand avec nos
invités en plateau mais avant tout ce
qu'il ne fallait pas louper dans
l'actualité européenne cette semaine du
vote des eurodéputés en faveur d'un
chargeur universel pour les smartphones
à la sortie officielle du royaume uni de
l'union européenne s'est résumé pour
vous comme chaque semaine par aurélie
d'afas les députés européens votent en
faveur du chargeur universel au nom des
droits des consommateurs et de
l'environnement
les euro députés adoptent à une très
large majorité une résolution demandant
à la commission de légiférer avant l'été
l'harmonisation de la connectique pour
les téléphones portables n'est pas une
idée neuve mais elle se heurte aux
réticences de l'industrie apple s'oppose
fermement à l'idée d'un chargeur
universel
c'est désormais à la commission
européenne de décider
la solidarité européenne se met en place
face aux coronavirus à la demande de la
france
l'union européenne a activé son
mécanisme de protection civile
elle prend donc en charge une partie du
coût des rapatriements des citoyens
européens
l'union va également faciliter
l'approvisionnement en fournitures
médicales d'urgence en réponse à la
demande du premier ministre chinois
la commission européenne annonce aussi
une subvention de 10 millions d'euros
pour soutenir la recherche sur le
coronavirus un appel d'urgence pour des
projets de recherche a été lancé
[Musique]
emmanuel macron en visite officielle en
pologne
les relations entre les deux pays sont
tendues depuis plusieurs années le
président français avait notamment
critiqué les réformes de la justice et
accuse la pologne de bloquer l'agenda de
neutralité carbone dans l'europe post
briques site la pologne renforce son
poids au sein de l'union
la france cherche donc à se rapprocher
les chefs d'état ont parlé d'un tournant
dans les relations entre les deux pays
joie et tristesse autour du bric site
alors que le royaume-uni devient le
premier pays à quitter l'union
européenne à bruxelles le parlement a
ratifié l'accord de divorce
un moment fort dans l'hémicycle avec les
adieux aux eurodéputés britanniques sur
l'airé possède ce n'est qu'un au revoir
pour d'autres c'est une célébration
les députés du parti du bric site quitte
bruxelles en jouer trois ans et demi
après le vote des britanniques
le compte à rebours a pris fin mais
s'ouvre désormais une nouvelle période
de négociation pour déterminer le cadre
de la future relations entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne
[Musique]
amandine est très speed bienvenue vous
êtes politologue enseignante à
l'université libre de bruxelles
nous venons de revoir un des images déjà
très commentée des eurodéputés
britanniques qui parquent ça y est donc
la sortie officielle a eu lieu mais le
plus dur il reste à venir il reste à
faire oui évidemment on voit que la
déclaration politique qui a été adopté
en octobre dernier
c'est vraiment des bonnes intentions et
que maintenant il faut passer au sujet
difficile et au détail de comment est-ce
qu'on va concrètement régler cette
relation commerciale économique entre le
royaume-uni et le reste de l'europe
parce que l'on ne divorce pas comme cela
de 47 ans de vie commune c'est compliqué
de sortir de l'union européenne
oui c'est compliqué c'est l'un des
grands enseignements de ce break site
qui peut être décourage d'autres partis
d'autres mouvements qui auraient pu
prenez la sortie de leur pays de l'union
européenne c'est compliqué beaucoup plus
que la majorité des gens ne leur ai
pensé sans doute parce que tout ce qui a
été fait sur le plan réglementaire qui
impacte la vie quotidienne dans les
réglementations dans les échanges
économiques n'est pas forcément perçue
très concrètement mais néanmoins
cruciales alors justement parlons du
calendrier
un boris johnson il a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'il ne voulait pas prolonger
la période de transition au delà du 31
décembre 2020 pourquoi une volonté
d'aller si vite quitte à se précipiter
et est-ce que c'est envisageable de tout
négocier d'ici la fin de l'année
on voit que depuis le début boris
johnson et l'adoptent une attitude assez
belliqueuse en tout cas une ligne dure
dans ces négociations de bréxent it son
slogan de campagne c'était c'est moi qui
ferai le break site gate bridge et john
ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a fait et c'est
qu'il veut continuer de faire je pense
relativement rapidement donc avec des
négociations qui ne traîne pas en
longueur alors ça c'est un slogan de
campagne la réalité de négociations on
le voit avec d'autres accords de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et le
canada les etats unis le mercosur qui
parfois train des dizaines d'années
c'est vrai que ça va être un défi
considérable de boucler ses négociations
en un an
certains estiment que ce n'est pas
possible et que donc on se mettra
d'accord sur des grandes lignes
certains sujets doivent être réglées en
tout cas c'est ce que les négociateurs
voudrait d'ici à l'été comme la pêche ou
les services financiers alors la
bataille de la pres a clairement
commencé le premier ministre britannique
vous l'avez dit semble durcir le ton il
veut s'affranchir de la tutelle de
l'union européenne écoutez boris johnson
et on en parle après minuit
il n'est pas nécessaire que l'accord de
libre-échange implique l'acceptation des
règles de l'union européenne sur la
concurrence
les subventions la protection sociale
l'environnement tout autre chose
similaire
pas plus que le lieu ne devrait être
obligé d'accepter les règles
britanniques le royaume uni maintiendra
les normes les plus élevées dans ces
domaines meyer à bien des égards que
celle de lieux sans être contraint par
un traité yeux
[Musique]
concrètement là est ce que boris johnson
affirme que le divorce il pourra être
définitivement consommée sans accord et
que ce n'est pas forcément un problème
oui on voit qu'il est toujours dans
cette attitude offensive d'un bric site
qui s'assume s'il n'obtient pas ce qu'il
veut dans ses négociations avec les
européens il est prêt à aller au no deal
ou presque no deal en tout cas et à voir
quitte à avoir des conditions des
échanges commerciaux peut être moins
favorable donc c'est une position
véritablement politique et je dirais
même symbolique plutôt que pragmatiques
ou ou économiques qu'elles sont
particulièrement les points
d'achoppement les points durs sur
lesquels il va falloir batailler rien la
pêche oui alors la pêche est apparu
effectivement ces derniers mois comme
une question particulièrement difficile
où chacun des partenaires est à la fois
en position de force est en position de
faiblesse donc c'est un exemple
intéressant pour montrer aussi les
interdépendances très étroite entre les
pays européens
les européens pêche massivement dans les
eaux britanniques qui sont à la fois
proche et aussi très très poissonneuses
mais les britanniques vendent en très
grande majorité
environ 70% de leurs produits de la
pêche aux européens
donc s'ils n'obtiennent pas l'accès au
marché unique finalement à quoi bon leur
servira de jouir de l'entièreté de leur
zone de pêche donc on voit bien que les
points tension se situe ici est dans une
situation qui est complexe
on voit que boris johnson essaye de
revenir en quelque sorte sur les
engagements pris dans la déclaration
politique d'octobre dernier à travers
laquelle les britanniques semblaient
s'engager à suivre plus ou moins les
standards européens
face à ce volte-face justement est ce
que l'union européenne elle va devoir
durcir le ton oui je crois que c'est ce
qu'elle est en train de faire à la fois
à travers la voix de la présidente de la
commission européenne
ursula von der leyen qui est allé
s'exprimer à londres récemment à travers
la voix de michel barnier qui tous les
deux martel finalement le même message
qu'ils ont martelé au cours des derniers
mois
c'est le credo de l'indivisibilité des
libertés de circulation au sein du
marché unique donc on ne peut pas avoir
une libre circulation des marchandises
sans tarifs douaniers
si on n'a pas à la fois un accord
minimum de garanties un minimum de
garanties que les standards sociaux
environnementaux seront les mêmes
alors on a beaucoup salué un durant ces
trois années de travail le travail
justement du négociateur en chef de
l'union européenne michel barnier
comment va-t-il réussir à garder les
vingt-sept unis face au royaume uni je
pense qu'il y a plus de chance de rester
unis si on garde les négociations dans
le cadre d'un accord global type c'est à
qui chercheraient à régler toutes les
questions
dans le cas où un accord global ne
s'avérait pas possible et où l'on se
dirigerait vers des négociations
d'accords particuliers secteur par
secteur
là on pourrait éventuellement voir
apparaître des dissensions entre
européens en fonction de leurs
différents intérêts qu'ils pourraient
avoir dans différents secteurs
affaire à suivre donc merci à moins
d'une crespy d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
on passe à un tout autre sujet en france
le bac est en cours de transformation et
suscite une forte opposition du monde
enseignant
les raisons de la colère moins
d'épreuves terminales et l'intégration
du contrôle continu dans la note finale
presque la copie conforme du bac
outre-rhin en tout cas sur le papier
notre reporter jonathan du prix s est
rendu en allemagne pour comprendre le
système de la biture le bac allemand
[Musique]
francfort sur l'odeur 1h30 à l'est de
berlin au lycée car l'hymne est 860
élèves
plus que quelques mois avant la bi tour
le bac allemand ce jour là les
terminales ont cours de français ok
alors bonjour
alors notre thème le monde du travail
est aujourd'hui plus précisément nous
allons parler en job d'été hormis trois
matières obligatoires
matt allemand est une langue étrangère
les lycéens détermine les spécialités
qu'ils ont envie d'étudier et se
construisent un bac presqu'à la carte
j'ai choisi des matières en fonction de
mes facilité pour avoir la meilleure
moyenne possible halabi tour j'ai pris
biologie parce que c'est important pour
mes études je voudrais faire médecine
plus tard ça devrait m'aider
et puis géographie parce que j'ai de
bonnes notes sur tout simplement c'est
derrick et vous allez travailler avec
charlotte et avec florian en plus de
choisir les enseignements qu'elle suit
et à choisira les matières qu'elles
passent quatre en tout l'examen final
compte pour un tiers de la note
les deux tiers restants sont évalués
grâce au contrôle continu depuis la
première un système qui a fait ses
preuves
selon le directeur du lycée toutefois le
feu young qui l'avantagent pour ces
élèves qui ne sont pas les plus à l'aise
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas besoin d'être à
100 % de leurs capacités le jour de
l'examen
pourtant ces élèves ont souvent beaucoup
de potentiel et donc pendant la première
et terminale ils ont le temps de montrer
de quoi ils sont capables d'actes
contrôle continu matière obligatoire si
ces modalités sont les mêmes pour tous
l'habit tour diffèrent suivant les
régions
al'inverse de la france la politique
éducative et décentralisé en allemagne
chacun des 16 länder décide de son
propre bac il y à différents bacs c'est
vrai qui varie selon la région où l'on
vit et même les examens sont différents
en allemand en mathématiques en biologie
en anglais par exemple mais en ce moment
les régions sont en train de développer
une banque d'épreuves communes pour les
épreuves obligatoires dans laquelle
elles pourront de plus en plus vers une
harmonisation de nos différents bacs
pour les rendre plus comparable les uns
avec les autres et à coeur cette banque
d'épreuves reste toutefois la discrétion
des régions et certaines rechignent à
l'utiliser mais le milieu scolaire
allemand s'écharpent sur une autre
question celle de la notation
en l'absence de barèmes commun pour le
contrôle continu
comment évaluer le niveau réel d'un
lycéen et la pertinence d'une note qui
fait débat ce sont les notes de contrôle
continu dans quelle mesure leur
attribution varient cette question ne
pourrait être réglé que s'ils ont
élaboré un standard de notation
indépendant commun aux établissements
pour attribuer
[Musique]
en l'absence de notre comparable se pose
la question de l'égal accès de tous à
l'université car la note à la bi tour
est le critère de sélection numéro 1 des
facs particulièrement sélective des
syndicats enseignants accusent même
certaines régions de surnoté leurs
élèves pour leur assurer une place en
fac
un problème que pointent les recteurs
d'universités dans certaines régions par
exemple en thuringe 38 % des élèves ont
une note supérieure à 13 me c'est à dire
une bonne note alors qu'en basse-saxe
seulement 17 % des élèves ont cette
moyenne là ça veut dire qu'on a de
grandes disparités de niveaux mais aussi
de notation et donc les notes sont de
moins en moins pertinents mais avec toi
de fait pour un élève qui a obtenu 1 18
par exemple en maths ou en sciences
naturelles
il faut déterminer dans quelle région
ils obtenu et c'est seulement comme ça
qu'on saura s'il est vraiment excellent
unique a été une année grosse parade
faute de pouvoir estimer la valeur de
l'élève sur la note d université
prestigieuse et très demandés comme la
freie à berlin ont décidé de durcir
leurs critères d'admission la fac
berlinoise valorise désormais les années
de césure les stages est beaucoup plus
regardante sur la cohérence entre
spécialités choisies par le lycéen et la
filière qui le visent romy 20 ans en a
fait l'expérience
c'est pas simple à berlin car beaucoup
de gens postule et avec le numerus
clausus les exigences sont élevés il
faut donc avoir un très bon ami tour
pour rentrer j'ai eu de la chance car ma
note n'était pas excellente
mais j'ai réussi à entrer ici surtout
parce que j'ai fait un stage dans ma
filière
et ça ça a joué
selon un récent sondage 80% des
allemands seraient favorables à un habit
tour pour tous mais même si le
gouvernement d'angela merkel pouce pour
plus d'harmonisation le pays attaché au
fédéralisme se heurte à l'hostilité de
régions comme la bavière qui redoutent
que leur bac
réputé difficile soit dévalorisé
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau tilly m bonjour vous êtes
luxembourgeois ge et vous saviez j'ai
ici au parlement européen au sein du
groupe les verts à vos côtés clotilde
armand eurodéputés roumaine roniu le
groupe centriste européen et puis face à
vous françois-xavier bellamy bonjour
vous êtes français député européen sous
l'étiquette du parti conservateur
le ppe bienvenue à tous les 3
françois-xavier bellamy on vient de le
voir dans le reportage le modèle du bac
allemand labit tour est ce que c'est un
modèle à suivre il ya des similitudes
avec le nouveau bac à la française
il ya des similitudes en effet mais ce
qui est très intéressant dans le
reportage que vous venez de montrer
c'est que l'allemagne est en train de
faire un chemin qui l inverse de celui
que nous faisons aujourd'hui en france
avec la réforme proposée par jean michel
blanquer
l'allemagne a réagi de façon très forte
au choc qu'a été pour l enquête pisa qui
publié il ya quelques années avait
montré que ces élèves n'étaient pas en
règle dans les milieux reprises et elle
a tenté d'abord d'harmoniser on le voit
les politiques éducatives entre les
différentes régions de rapprocher par
exemple les systèmes de notation
et puis de diminuer la spécialisation
qui était offerte aux lycéens en offrant
un tronc commun plus solide de culture
générale nous faisons exactement inverse
aujourd'hui en france c'est à dire que
nous décentralisons l'évaluation à
travers des épreuves qui ne sont pas
vraiment des épreuves de contrôle
continu on n'a pas fait un choix clair
et donc elles sont très complexes pour
les établissements mais elles vont être
beaucoup moins lisible et le bac sera
beaucoup moins nationale et puis
simultanément nous accélérons la
spécialisation au lieu de transmettre
cette culture générale dont je crois les
élèves ont besoin plus que jamais
aujourd'hui au luxembourg 6 1 le
contrôle continu et prises en compte ce
n'est pas le cas en roumanie où tout on
mise tout sur le jour j c'est une bonne
chose ça de ne pas prendre en compte le
contrôle continu avec le type d'armé en
roumanie et de très fortes inégalités
donc le problème que l'on voit en
allemagne avec les différences entre les
régions les régions en roumanie ce
serait ce serait terrible on a un
système qui est très élitiste c'est à
dire qu'on a des très bons élèves qui
sont eux mêmes dans les meilleurs
internationaux dans certaines écoles
dans certaines grandes villes
et puis à la campagne on un pays très
rural le niveau est très bas donc on
et qu'il faut on sait qu'il faut
investir massivement dans les années des
rurales dans les zones rurales on sait
qu'il faut remettre à l'honneur
l'enseignement technique qui a
totalement disparu
donc on a beaucoup de choses à faire
mais je pense qu'il est important de
manière à avoir la même la même
évaluation pour tout le monde d'avoir un
seul examen puisqu'il y aurait trop de
différences de disparités régionales
alors justement en allemagne en roumanie
mais aussi en france certains dénoncent
un manque d'égalité avec un diplôme qui
ne serait pas le même pour tous je vous
propose d'écouter un professeur français
qui fait grève contre la nouvelle
formule du baccalauréat et puis on en
reparle après nous étions convoqués par
les surveillances nous avons nous
exerçons notre droit de grève parce que
nous considérons que les os 3 c c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est en train
de casser le bac le bac n'est plus un
diplôme national ça devient diplôme
locale un diplôme maison avec toutes les
inégalités que ça entraîne
nous refusons c'est pour ça que nous
exerçons notre droit de grève alors le
professeur parle 2 3 c'est un jeu
précise que ce sont les épreuves
communes de contrôle continu mm le même
diplôme pour tous c'est ça l'enjeu
comment ça se passe chez vous au
luxembourg luxembourg effectivement on a
un bac nationale au lia selon les
spécialisations qu'on choisit un certain
nombre de branches qu'on doit passer il
ya un petit pourcentage où on considère
aussi l'évaluation continue
il ya d euros il ya surtout des écrits
donc ça reste à mes yeux quand même
aussi assez traditionnel sauf pour les
spécialisations moi je viens de la
formation des éducateurs éducatrices où
il ya vraiment la prise en compte du
stage qui est une autre très importante
aussi et qui continue quand même à il
obtienne aussi un bac à travers cette
formation duale donc qui se base sur ce
stage et en plus sur des cours
théoriques et d euros et de là
de l'évaluation continue donc au
luxembourg il a plutôt un même diplôme
pour tous françois dally bellamy on
entendre un enseignant en grève
vous comprenez leur revendication non
seulement je la comprends mais je la
soutiens je suis professeur de
philosophie et j'ai exercé jusqu'à mon
élection ici l'été dernier et je crois
que ce qui se joue d'ailleurs dans cette
réforme est la manière dont elle est
mise en oeuvre c'est un mépris très
profond du métier d'enseignant du
travail de l'évaluation et du travail
des élèves
en fait ces épreuves n'ont pas été
préparées elles se déroulent dans des
conditions de désorganisation absolument
invraisemblable on a des établissements
dans lesquels les sujets ont circulé
avant que l'épreuve ne soit passé
d'autres établissements dans lesquels
des élèves ce film même avec leur
téléphone portable en réalisant leur
épreuve
on voit bien que tout ça n'est pas
sérieux rappelons que le baccalauréat
c'est le premier grade universitaire en
france c'est à dire que c'est une
manière aussi je crois que c'est très
important nous l'avons vécue comme cela
nous aussi comme élève d'avoir ce rite
de passage mais le contrôle continu et
c'est aussi peut-être un moyen justement
de lutter contre les injustices et
d'évaluer sur un plus long terme c'est
le cas au luxembourg qu'il y met
oui effectivement je pense que en
général dans l'éducation faut tenir
compte des savoirs des savoir-faire des
savoir être et savoir devenir maintenant
tout ce qui est est bizarre et je dois
quand même dire aussi au luxembourg le
bac traditionnel il ce focus beaucoup
sur des savoirs plutôt théorique
quelques savoirs faire et très peu sur
des compétences sociales sur une
certaine attitude sur des compétences
morale etc
et puis je pense qu'au luxembourg un
grand obstacle parce que malheureusement
malgré qu'on tienne compte de
l'évaluation continue on constate au
luxembourg que là où je me trouve les
études que je fais les résultats que
j'ai à l'école sont fort déterminé quand
même par le niveau socio économique
social d'où je viens
donc on peut pas dire que l'ascenseur
social fonctionne même au luxembourg où
on tient plus compte peut-être d'autres
critères aussi pour l'évaluation
on le voit bien au sein de l'union
européenne il ya des disparités fortes
un seul pour le baccalauréat et sur les
différentes formes de baccalauréat même
si cela demeure de la compétence des
états ce qu'il faudrait pas envisager
une tentative d'harmonisation on a un
exode
on a un
1 furent une fuite des cerveaux qui est
absolument dramatique se dire que l'état
roumain investi forme des jeunes gens
qui chaque année ce sont les meilleurs
qui partent
je vous donne un exemple pour que vous
compreniez l'ampleur du phénomène on a
10% des médecins exerçant en roumanie
qui s'en vont chaque année 110 % des
médecins avec les montants que l'on a
investi pour les formes et cela
représente un tiers des montants de la
politique de cohésion vous savez ces
fameux fonds pour aider au rattrapage
économique cela représente un tiers des
moments de cohésion juste pour les
médecins je ne voudrais pas mentionné
les dentistes je ne vais pas mentionner
des infirmières des ingénieurs les
chercheurs donc la roumanie et c'est la
même chose dans les autres pays de l'est
ont investi massivement dans une élite
finalement qu' elle part dans le pays
donc bien sûr il faut qu'on revoie notre
système mais il faut également qu'au
niveau de l'europe on prenne en compte
le fait que le ski n'est pas investi
dans par la france par le luxembourg
bien finalement est comblé par des pays
comme les nôtres qui déjà ont des
ressources bien moindre et qui voit ses
ressources profiter au pays de l'ouest
françois-xavier bellamy vous êtes
d'accord avec clotilde armand qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour éviter justement
la fuite des cerveaux de l'est vers les
autres pays de l'union européenne est ce
qu'il faut harmoniser un petit peu
l'enseignement le baccalauréat et autres
au sein de l'union européenne
alors il faut faire en sorte que cette
fuite des cerveaux effectivement soit
soit limitée ce qui ne passe que par le
fait qu effectivement nos économies
puissent marcher du même marcher du même
pas aussi en ce sens que la rémunération
sera plus attractive en roumanie de
manière à pouvoir y maintenir les
esprits que vous aurez fort mais moi je
crois pas qu'il faille centralisée
l'éducation au niveau européen on voit
déjà comme chacun de nos pays a du mal à
ajuster la réponse éducative à la
population à laquelle elle doit
s'adresser
je pense aussi qu'il ya des différences
dans les cultures dans les traditions
éducatif qu'il faut pouvoir respecter
mais je crois en revanche que nous
devrions et je parle là pour mon pays
aussi avec peut-être plus d'humilité
regarder ce qui fonctionne ailleurs
regardez ce qui a marché dans d'autres
pays pour pouvoir nous en inspirer je
pense à ce qui s'est fait en allemagne
par exemple effectivement depuis
quelques années je pense si on en voit
les limites on l'a vu dans les
reportages les
du modèle allemand bien sûr mais à
falaise les allemands partez quand même
d'assez loin puisqu'il ya 20 ans il
était dans une situation très critique
nous en france nous avons un problème
majeur qui est que nous avons le système
scolaire qui est l'un des plus
inégalitaires de tous les pays de l'
ocde dire que notre moyenne ne veut pas
dire grand chose d'un côté certains
réussissent très bien mais de l'autre
certains sont en grande situation de
difficulté et malheureusement le
parcours scolaire d'un élève et en
france très directement corrélé à son
milieu social d'origine ce qui est un
scandale du point de vue de la promesse
de l'égalité républicaine il faut
absolument que nous puissions regarder
ailleurs
je pense en particulier dans ce contexte
de briques ce sera peut-être un peu
provocant mais je pense à ce qui s'est
fait en grande bretagne où il ya eu un
travail remarquable pour réinvestir les
savoirs fondamentaux
mais aujourd'hui on le sait la grande
bretagne a de bons résultats dans les
classements pisa et dans le domaine
éducatif
alors justement derrière les réformes à
l'enjeu c'est la qualité de
l'enseignement et puis le niveau des
élèves et là il faut regarder l'enquète
qui est un classement réalisé un parent
à l'os et de tous les trois ans un
mauvais classement d'allemagne dans les
années 2000 vous l'avez dit avait poussé
le pays à réformer son système éducatif
la france arrive en 23e position un peu
derrière l'allemagne le luxembourg et la
roumanie
vous n'êtes plus loin est-ce que ce
classement il veut dire quelque chose
qui m oui il faut relativiser ce qui est
bien dans tout ce qui est bizarre c'est
qu'on se remette en question qu'en
remettant cristiano système d'éducation
ça c'est très bien
de l'autre côté quand je regarde
maintenant pour le luxembourg tous les
tests sans passer pour la plupart des
élèves pas dans leur langue maternelle
donc on a une très grande hétérogénéité
au luxembourg point de vue langue
maternelle plus de 50% des élèves ne
sont pas luxembourgeois et les tests ne
sont pas faits en luxembourgeois ni dans
leur nom donc ce qui est certainement un
obstacle
et puis le design en cette évaluation
toutes les trois on s'est quand même des
objectifs à très court terme
et puis comme je les dis ton tour on
n'évalue pas d'autres compétences
essentielles et des attitudes c'est ça
une visée économique quelque part les
tests pisa donc moi je voudrais quand
même aussi des citoyens des citoyennes
critiques qu'ils soient flexibles qui
est une certaine envie et attitudes
d'apprendre et tout ça le test pisa donc
il faut forcément qu'on ne prouve
relativiser je précise quand même que le
premier pays
l'union européenne dans ce classement
c'est l'estonie qui parle dans la
cinquième position qui depuis plusieurs
années a mis la priorité sur la qualité
de l'enseignement à la petite enfance le
pays a également donné des primes aux
enseignants est-ce que vous avez un
commentaire sur ce que l'estonie a mis
en place avec le type d'armes en moi je
pense que ont tout misé sur la petite
enfance
et puis revaloriser le travail des
enseignants il faut il faut absolument
revaloriser le métier
le métier d'enseignant dans des pays
dont l'économie s'est effondrée alors je
vois que ils ont bien pris le taureau
par les cornes l'estonie mais dans dans
les pays comme la bulgarie la roumanie
lorsqu'il me fondre monde économie un
effondrement des budgets de l'état se
sont finalement souvent l'éducation des
enseignants qui en pâtissent et ce sont
des métiers qui sont
qui ne sont pas reconnus qui ne sont pas
considérés donc il va falloir faire un
effort énorme pour reconsidérer ses
métiers et notamment sur les métiers
techniques
il ya eu un dévaloriser ans une des
balles aux filières reconnaissance
sociale de très faibles de ces métiers
les écoles techniques ont été fermés
notamment incroyable par les
gouvernements socialistes
donc il va falloir absolument hors garde
m on a une nouvelle économie que
l'europe veut lancer il va falloir qu'on
remette des nouveaux métiers qu'on forme
des gens dans ces métiers
françois-xavier bellamy un dernier
commentaire sur la recette du modèle
estonien s'il enquêtes pisa a toujours
montré quelque chose c'est que le
facteur décisif pour la qualité de
l'éducation c'est l'enseignant et donc
il faut investir pour avoir de bons
enseignants pour les rémunérer comme il
faut pour pouvoir attirer les meilleurs
et puis pour pouvoir les former
correctement et la dernière chose que je
voulais dire pour revenir sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est à titre
personnel je ne crois pas du tout qu'on
puisse opposer les savoirs et les
compétences je pense que nous ne sommes
ouverts roulement nous nous sommes
rendus capables d'apprendre de nous
mettre en relation avec les autres que
par des savoirs traits fondamentaux que
nous avons pu recevoir la lecture
l'écriture les capacités de calcul qui
construisent la raison critique c'est
cette transmission d'un héritage qui
fait que nous sommes capables d'inventer
notre avenir et je crois que c'est ça le
grand pari éducatif qu'il faut savoir
retrouver très bien merci à tous les
trois ce seront les mots de la fin c'est
la fin de cette émission vous pouvez la
voir en replay sur le site de public
sénat mais aussi à l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures robert
[Musique]